[Music]
exciting red-carpet exciting night for
you I mean it's a big I know I'm excited
make me is nominated for music Lee's top
covered so I'm really excited I'm
nervous I'm like can we find out already
like I'm like having a panic attack I'm
so excited for Miley I'm literally so
proud of her I'm getting all kind of
emotional for Miley cuz I'm really happy
for her
I'm just so excited to be here with her
and like watch her perform I know you
guys are supportive of each other but
have you given Miley any advice on
anything we always go back and forth
about what we're doing with our hair so
she'll be like should I do a part or
should I not should I put it up so we
always do that so it's more like advice
with like hair makeup like style type
things recently you said at this phase
of your career you're still trying to
figure out what kind of artist you are
or who you are as an artist so who do
you think you are right now what is that
artist I think when I'm performing like
I'm so little shy and like I'm like
learning how to kind of be comfortable
like in my own skin just like I Know Who
I am like music wise it's just like well
I'm very performing I played Wango Tango
and I was like the biggest crowd I've
ever performed in front of and it was
like one big heart attack for me I like
literally was shaking as I went onstage
you